Martin Heidegger is without doubt the
most incomprehensible German philosopher
that ever lived
nothing quite rivals the prose in his
masterpiece being in time which is
filled with complex-compound German
words like zines Ferguson Haight Borden
stand a kite and visions for fussing yet
beneath the jargon Heidegger tells us
some simple even at times homespun
truths about the meaning of our lives
the sicknesses of our time and the
routes to freedom we should bother with
him he was born and in many ways
remained a rural provincial German who
left picking mushrooms walking in the
countryside and going to bed early he
hated television aeroplanes pop music
and processed food at one time he'd been
a supporter of Hitler but saw the error
of his ways much of his life he spent in
a hut in the woods away from modern
civilization he diagnosed modern
humanity our suffering from a number of
diseases of the soul firstly we have
forgotten to notice were alive we know
it in theory of course but we aren't
day-to-day properly in touch with a
sheer mystery of existence the mystery
of what Heidegger called design or in
English being it's only at a few odd
moments perhaps late at night or when
we're ill and have been alone all day or
are on a walk through the countryside
that we come up against the uncanny
strangeness of everything why things
exist as they do why we're here rather
than there why the world is like it is
what we're running away from is a
confrontation with the opposite of being
what Heidegger called best needs than
nothing the second problem is we've
forgotten that all being is connected
most of the time our jobs and daily
routines make us egoistic and focused we
treat others and nature as means and not
as ends but occasionally and again walks
in the country are particularly
conducive to this realization we may
step outside our narrow orbit and take a
more expansive view we may sense what
Heidegger termed the unity of being
noticing for example that we and that
ladybird on the bark and that rock and
that cloud over there are all in
existence right now and are
fundamentally united by the basic fact
our common being Heidegger values these
moments immensely and wants us to use
them as the springboard to a deeper form
of generosity an overcoming of
alienation and egoism and a more
profound appreciation of the brief time
that remains to us before death needs
claims us in turn the third problem is
we forget to be free and to live for
ourselves much about us isn't of course
very free we are in Heidegger's unusual
formulation thrown into the world at the
start of our lives thrown into a
particular and narrow social milieu
surrounded by rigid attitudes archaic
prejudices and practical necessities not
of our own making the philosopher wants
to help us to overcome this thrown us
give off and height as he put it in
German by understanding it we need to
grasp our psychological social and
professional provincialism and then rise
above it to a more universal perspective
in so doing we'll make the classic
Heidegger Ian journey away from UN
agency height to ican't Lee height from
inauthenticity to authenticity we will
in essence start to live for ourselves
and yet most of the time for Heidegger
we failed dismally at this task we
merely surrender to a socialized
superficial mode of being he called they
self as opposed to ourselves we follow
the chatter the skier leader in German
which we hear about in the newspapers on
TV and in the large cities that
Heidegger hated to spend time in what
will help us to pull away from the they
self is an appropriately intense focus
on our own upcoming death it's only when
we realize that other people cannot save
us from the Snead's that we're likely to
stop living for them to stop worrying so
much about what others think and to
cease giving up the lion's share of our
lives and energies to impress people who
never really liked us in the first place
when in a lecture in 1961 Heidegger was
asked how we should better lead our
lives
he replied Ursula that we should simply
aim to spend more time in graveyards it
would be lying to say that Heidegger's
meaning and moral
ever very clear nevertheless what he
tells us is intermittently fascinating
wise and surprisingly useful despite the
extraordinary words and language in a
sense we know a lot of it already we
merely need reminding and embolden
akitsu riously which the odd prose style
may help us to do we know in our hearts
that it's time to overcome our give off
and height that we should become more
conscious of deaths needs day to day and
that we owe it to ourselves to escape
the clutches of dusk gear leader for the
sake of eigentlich height with a little
help from that graveyard
you